quel est votre projet j'ai interrogé 3
schizophrène qui prétendent être jésus
joseph kessel kleitz benson les ongs à
bord je voulais mettre tous les trois
dans la même pièce et étudier leur
comportement
que pourrait-il se produire si nous
tenons ces réunions c'est parce qu'il ne
peut y avoir qu'un seul jésus un seul et
unique chat de prétendus qui s'écaille
adressez vous à moi comme à votre
seigneur votre dieu vous ne pouvez pas
franchir les limites imposées par le
protocole clinique
cette expérience est très importante et
courageuse et une approche respectueuse
bat électrochoc ni de médication
la sécurité des patients et ma
responsabilité
un homme sérieux à force d'endurer fini
par se briser et il tapait pas le retour
vous m'avez sauvé de l'électrocution
vous avez ma gratitude infinie
pourquoi voulez vous travailler avec des
schizophrène paranoïde parce qu'ils sont
très seuls
votre travail novateur et anchois à vous
de décider si les bénéfices possibles
justifie les risques encourus
regardez il commence sans qu'on leur
dise
[Musique]
je mets fin à l'expérience avez vous
peur de moi pouces est l'homme le plus
puissant de cette institution
l'année un cran
mais il ya des limites à ne pas franchir
ce régime en mesure de fournir à ses
hommes les moyens de découvrir qu'ils
sont
[Musique]
faites bien attention